in these times of Economic and political
turmoil all eyes on the PM put in on a
brave face but facing a barrage of
questions have you wrecked the economy
prime minister time for another U-turn
is it all going to plan
heading to only her second pmqs and the
fast since that mini budget that spooked
the market and a party too
now being told to backtrack when will
she stop ducking responsibility do the
right thing and reverse her Kamikaze
budget which is causing so much pain
Mr Speaker I'm genuinely unclear
so what
so what the labor party's policy is on
our energy price guarantee sticking to
her plans on tax cuts and spending too
the Prime Minister said and I quota
exactly I'm very clear I'm not planning
public spending reductions is she going
to stick to that
absolutely absolutely what we will make
sure is that over the medium term the
debt is falling but we will do that not
by cutting public spending but by making
sure we spend public money well that's a
pledge from a PM now under pressure on
all sides MPS and voters don't want to
return to austerity but after big
spending nervous markets want to plan to
balance the books for her Chancellor
more u-turns perhaps the only way
through I think he's very close to the
kind of territory where some movement
there may actually be necessary I just
think it's
extraordinarily important that whatever
the chancellor comes forward with on the
31st that that cuts it with the markets
and if there's any doubt in his mind
about anything he's doing in that
package he would do well to
think again
is there a way back a chance for a reset
or is the damage already done that's
what MPS around this place are talking
about while the Prime Minister herself
is trying to win colleagues around going
to the tea rooms after pmqs and
addressing her back benches she wants a
second chance but some MPS tell me
privately they think it's too late as
one former cabinet minister put it to me
recently in their view trust has ruined
the party ruined the country ruined the
prospects for the next general election
they told me they thought the damage was
done and she'd have to go but for now
the PM pressing ahead her fast weekly
audience with the new King two new
leaders but his future Farm were assured
than hers Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster